last year the new york times published
the 1619
project an immensely ambitious
influential
and controversial reframing of american
history
the project's creator nicole hannah
jones who won a pulitzer prize for her
work argued that the u.s constitution
was a decidedly
undemocratic document and that
anti-black racism runs in the very dna
of this country
our country says that we are founded to
be a democracy
but we were actually founded as a
slaveocracy this interpretation of the
american founding has been the subject
of a heated debate the 1619 project has
also been adapted into a high school
curriculum that attempts to
reframe u.s history by marking the year
when the first enslaved africans arrived
on virginia soil as our nation's
foundational date
after the 1619 project was attacked by
five eminent historians
the project's editor responded by
reiterating hannah jones's view
that advances for minority groups have
almost always come as a result of
political and social struggles in which
african americans have generally taken
the lead not as a working out of the
imminent logic of the constitution
but this view of the constitution and
the declaration of independence
is at odds with that of frederick
douglass the escaped slave
abolitionist author and towering figure
in american history
in his new book a glorious liberty
frederick douglass and the fight for an
anti-slavery constitution reasoned
senior editor damon root looks at the
arguments that took place in the middle
of the 19th century over racism
and america's founding which are being
replayed today
if you look at what frederick douglass
and william lloyd garrison were fighting
over in 1840s and 1850s
you see what people are fighting about
right now which is was the founding just
a pro-slavery compact
and douglas completely rejects that as a
former slave douglas
had no illusions about racism but his
view of the constitution which he called
a glorious liberty document would put
him at odds with
many of its contemporary critics
douglas's challenge really is that the
constitution and the declaration of
independence
lay out these powerful principles but
why don't we live up to them
clearly the nation is not living up to
those principles habeas corpus due
process of law the right to keep and
bear arms any of those things if sort of
fully enforced that's you know slavery
can't stand and he would point that out
again and again and again
root argues that douglas was a classical
liberal who believed in the primacy of
individual rights
and economic freedom one of his
intellectual adversaries was the slavery
apologist
george fitzhugh whose 1854 book
sociology for the south or the failure
of free society
defended slavery by repudiating the
principles of liberalism
he has this attack on john locke attack
on adam smith attack on all these
liberal principles and you see frederick
douglass picking up the banner of those
principles and making it the bedrock
of his all-out war on slavery he talked
about the powerful experience of earning
his first free dollar
on the docks in new bedford
massachusetts when he escapes and what
that meant to him that he was now his
own master a tremendous factory rights
in his one of his autobiographies
it all comes back to this idea of
self-ownership locke's theory of
self-ownership
property rights begins with the
ownership in yourself and everything
blows out from that
unlike many of his contemporaries
douglas extended his beliefs in
unalienable individual rights to women
as well
in 1848 he attended the seneca falls
convention that
launched the women's suffrage movement
there are 100 people at the seneca falls
convention he's one of 32 many he's the
only black person there
he takes the radical position alongside
elizabeth katie stanton that um women
should have not just
a whole host of other legal privileges
that they're denied at the time but
women should have the right to vote
stanton said that was almost too radical
for the convention there were people who
were against it they thought oh we can't
go that far and
douglas is right there shoulder to
shoulder with her on that issue douglas
would have a bitter falling out with
elizabeth katie stanton and other
suffragettes
after the civil war when only former
male slaves got the right to vote but he
would reconcile with them later in his
life
the last thing that douglas does the day
he dies is he attends a women's rights
meeting that's his last public act and
he goes home and
dies of either a heart attack or a
stroke he falls dead in his home
so he goes out doing what he always did
fighting for the liberty and equality
in a country that seems more divided
along racial and ethnic lines than it
has been in decades
root says that frederick douglass's
belief and principles undergirding the
american founding have a lot to teach us
about how to build a society based on
mutual respect
empathy and individualism douglas he
says
stress that rights for one or rights for
all ending slavery
was also something that benefited the
country as a whole slavery is a
pernicious institution it's economically
crippling all these sorts of things
free labor system benefits whites and
blacks to the extent that a civil rights
cause looks like it just benefits one
group in fact the benefits are
far and wide to all involved that's
certainly a lesson we can we can
continue to take today
the nation's founding doesn't need to be
dialed back to 1619 to acknowledge the
horrific legacy of slavery and honor the
major role
played by african americans in the
nation's history we would do well not
only to remember the example set by
frederick douglass in his life
but also to embrace his understanding of
the constitution as a glorious liberty
document whose ideals of freedom and
equality we must
never stop fighting to realize
[Music]